that great energy and Gordon leading the
charge BAM Adebayo
check down to Tyler Johnson still
getting it done in somewhat limited
minutes for the heat still win the
ballgame pray y'all get a steal by
quaint Wade runs with Tyler Johnson
Galloway Trey young seven double doubles
as a rookie to have come against Miami
water circus shot by way to 360 spin a
backhanded flip he has 11 the heater
down by 15 left in the fourth quarter
Whiteside is back and replacing BAM
finishes is country strong for a sad
white shadow
[Applause]
the play though we hit him with the
Smitty hip rate will set up shop covered
by Danny Green comes left shoots a three
[Applause]
places so it stands charged and
Covington up front for them a cookie
black bite wait wait
coming back this way with Tyler Johnson
[Applause]
weighed against setter aunty
yes sir now with twisting Shafter he
weighed he has nine they heat up by ten
weight getting down and dirty right here
a little whirling dervish Hey
Collins has it but throws it to a heat
player and that's Jones gets it ahead to
wade leads for the Derrick Jones Jam but
this is just a beautiful pass here
though you got a young guy coming down
who was a former slam dunk champion this
goes up and gets it second foul on every
Lane weight finding James Johnson
as two points so far say 12 - Kevlar sir
wait hit in the face and he hit a touch
shots it's ready for D way explode some
time to think of it
give me where you think Wade ranks all
time and two guards in the NBA I guess
he just went up the ladder up the ladder
oh so so that was right on time right
there time way back machine there's no
question now this is where Miami will
control tempo and they can control tempo
on the G way is a pole he's ready we've
got a sister time is per hive it's a
three
[Applause]
if Audrey trips up shot clock at seven
hey d-don't sweet spot let's get a fan
went came over the double-team push a
headphone
under 500 yeah wait got it got the block
gets the hoop all that experience for
Dwyane Wade
Durant never saw incoming until they'd
already committed you look at this
brilliant play by Wade and you go back
to the free-throw here's curry for
checked into the dribble flips it ahead
and broke it up
Durant for Wade Walker back his wave
seven
[Applause]
what it is you called it and here's off
the back worth the old teammates
back-to-back champion Miami Heat
wait got like Andre Drummond who could
take over him
Dwayne lead against Bruce grab types of
deep scores and trust the foul
mic one of the season ticket-holders
remember season taking all the remembers
you can remove this week is member
appreciation week calendar way we got
some big-time action going here for Mike
we got to reenact this one right here
look at this up and under on the shop
block or homes Wade draws them and then
gets to the right look at the spinny has
to put on the ball it is not in the box
underrated team defensively they're so
good offensive weight with a shield
nobody home
[Applause]
ten seconds one weighed against Iguodala
five seconds well waiters back to 12
shoots no I couldn't get it off that
fires it up
[Applause]
126 to 125
in his final game against the colo State
Warriors Dwyane Wade beats the worries
how well they've shot the ball beyond
the earth or 14 of 28 now that's 50%
what a great pass
Wade setup man for a silver platter slam
Richardson Smith's taken by Lowery he's
off and running stops at the three-point
line and weight comes away with a seal
racing with Larry Thank You Saul it's a
big part of being a great defender wage
shooting the gap there Larry made the
cardinal sin of getting stuck up in the
air
almost down the bow shot clock runs out
then at 15 left in the first day George
Hill blocked by Whiteside second quarter
the game for the big man Wade
[Applause]
butter five minutes left heat a hit by
ten three yes
[Applause]
five out of its last seven spend of
about three minutes to get back in it
his neighbor has it poked away well set
up the floor blade release the screen
it's like that it's a four-point game
way we did it again Dwyane Wade thirty
fourth block of his final season waders
[Applause]
exactly apply a little pressure in the
backcourt here the laneway
about it
he just gets all the way to half-court
let that one fly
and it's kind of kennel Miami 11 432 the
Bucs 14 429 behind the earth wave blocks
Wetzel and d-wade one of the best two
guards shot blockers in the history of
the game still has the timing at 37
years old a screen from some one side
but then takes one flips it up to the
side throws it down
nobody does it better engaging Whiteside
to D way
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what will be an unforgettable Dwyane
Wade Miami Heat adventure
we're starting any better you say you
had a better career than Twain wait
[Music]
[Applause]
three again
[Applause]
[Music]
there's one wish to look ahead next she
should let it be a better year at home
yeah absolutely give these fans
[Applause]
north and look who's in the house LeBron
James Chris Paul Carmelo Anthony here to
support their friends Dwyane Wade what a
special seat here in Brooklyn at
Barclays Center
and for this Nets organizations than
these myths flying start before that
awful foot injury here's twin
perfect and uh Udonis you did it again
eight points for Aslan tonight the just
reward and flight your last two games
alongside your brother's team 21
downtown but Duncan Robinson with ten
points off the bench 2014 where an
assister well somebody cut you Dennis
[Applause]
score
here we're gonna see the quick burst and
then the driving kick and that's going
to get up the triple double up with the
assistant that's you 252 the countdown
has moved inside of three minutes
there's way up three a parting gift
the last seconds of Dwyane Wade's career
[Applause]
Hugh doesn't seem stronger than
how about me lucky we'll never forget
you
[Applause]
his basketball career is over let the
rest of his life begin with all the
peace joy and happiness one man and one
family can handle what up its your boy
Adam left coach you like that content I
know you like that content hit subscribe
for more of it from Bleacher Report